تم تعاوين قديمه جديده لا تكاد التغيب عن
الساحه السياسيه
الملفات اا الملفات
وهي ملفات ترثها الحكومات المتعاقبه
ويراقبها الجميع فما الذي
سيفعله محمد شياع السوداني بهذه الملفات
المفخخه السوداني لديه فرصه كبيره
اقتصاديا لوضع البلاد على سكه الاصلاح
سلفه مصطفى الكاظمي ترك احتياطات ماليه
ضخمه وهي تقدر بنحو 85 مليار دولار في
الخزينه ومئه وثلاثين طوما من الذهب لم
يسبق لرئيس حكومه عراقيه عن حاضيه بمثل
هذه الميزات خاصه منذ عام 2014 وحتى تشكيل
حكومه الكاظم
مالي ضخم ودعم الاخر
السودانيه محبوبه بدعم برلمانيا سياسيا
طويله لكن السودان المدعوم مقيد لماذا
ابتهاله لجهه سياسيه متورطه ايضا بالفساد
وهذا يفتح الباب امام تساؤلات عديده حول
نهج السوداني وان كان يجرا على طرق باب
الفساد حتى الرجل اطلق تصريحا من هيئه
النزاهه لا خطوط حمراء امام اي ملف فساد
تحركنا في وجه الفساد اذن لكن هناك تحركا
اخر
هدى على انه انتقام السياسي من الكاظم
وربما يتبعه لاحقا انتقام من الصدر
والسوداني الغى قرارات قرارات اللي سلفه
هو افعى عشرات المسؤولين ومصطفى هذه
الخطوات
قالت مناصب حساسه في الدوله وشاملت رئيس
جهاز الاستخبارات القاضي رائد روحي ورئيس
جهاز الامن الوطني حميد
خطوه تثير القلق حول ما اذا كان الاطار
التنسيقي يصفي حساباته لكن الاطار ينفي
والسوداني يؤكد انها اعاده هيكله اللافت
ان اللواء الركن حامد السهيري قائد الفرقه
الخاصه لحمايه المنطقه الخضراء قيل لعدم
تصده لانصار التيار الصدري العز الحين
اقتحمه المنطقه الخضراء الصغير الصيف
الماضي والمفارقات الحث الشعبي اقتحم
بدبباباته ومدرعاته المنطقه الخضراء فيما
يلعب الماضي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]